okay for people joining this live stream
this is looking at some incremental
language development topics for wolven
language
and first on our list has is things to
do with trees
right so here we are adding options to
trees
and this only involves standard options
not annotations for a moment
so yeah can you explain
right so the idea is that some of the
options will be global and for those
will take the options from the root
and then other options allow you to
specify things
uh by position
those are
local options so the main issue is
what seeps down the tree and how do we
specify that
and what
what is the tree and this on all its sub
trees
this tree element and all its sub trees
and
what's this tree element on its own is
that correct
yes
so what's an example of an option
excuse me that is um
okay so tree color
oh boy
so color is a local option but for
example aspect ratio is a global option
why can't you set aspect ratio for a
subtree
because graphics and graph don't do it
and it will be difficult
so it could happen that eventually some
of the global options are promoted to
local but at the moment most of the
graphics standard options
we consider global
okay
so
i mean but not all graph options make
any sense here like graph layout doesn't
make any sense right
we have no we have graph layout
it's one of the only graph specific
options that we
directly have
but
like for example laying out the trees
sideways up down whatever
yeah isn't there a better way to do that
the only way i'm aware of to do that is
with graph layout and that's a sub
option to layered embedding
um
don't we have doesn't tree plot
support
options much more directly for
[Music]
yeah puts places the root whatever
that position whatever
what does that mean
so
for this case we have to say what the
root is right
for a tree plot we have to say what the
root is because we don't know
intrinsically or do we know
we could know from the structure of the
graph
so
there's something slightly screwy about
this
oh look
well i see this could be a multi-rooted
tree
so it has a second argument which is the
position
okay so
i claim that tree
should have some kind of tree
orientation option
yeah i'm fine with that what would that
be analogous to don't we have something
similar to that someplace else
there's a
sub-option of the layered embedding
called orientation that works just like
this
okay so why don't we do this when we add
tree orientation also as an option to
tree plot just for consistency even
though it's supported as a second
argument
okay
um
now in tree we don't get to have
multi-trees as in
multi-rooted trees right
that's correct
okay
all right so
i mean
are you sure we shouldn't have something
called tree layout
because i can imagine other things like
for example the fact that these are yes
so an argument against graph layout is
that
you when you're specifying sub options
some of them allow you to specify a
particular vertex for some reason or
other and in that you're using like an
index
so we might want a tree layout let's not
have a graph like let's not use graphite
help for the subject so like if you use
a tree at layout then we can actually
use positions which is
how all of the other like we don't have
vertex
labels but we do have tree label
because they they take positions i think
what we should do is have a thing called
tree layout
analogous to graph layout
and i think it should allow you to
specify things like are these diagonals
or they do they come out you know from
the one coming out you know what i'm
saying they're different ways to draw
this right
i
are you did so are you saying having
tree layout that does all of the same
things as graph layout or tree layout no
there's additional new kind no
completely different kinds of things if
it so happens that we can use a graph
layout
capability for tree layout fantastic but
that's under the hood and done by us
like for example
do we want to have the capability to
have
a tree
done with spring electrical embedding
does that even make any sense
did you understand what i'm asking
do you understand what i'm asking
yeah i do yeah
there are multiple representations of
trees but i'm not sure what you mean by
makes sense you like right now i have
implemented you can plot this tree in a
spring electrical embedding
okay question like would we want to be
able to do that i don't i don't know
it's already supported so okay fine i
understand that but i mean in
something like a hyperbolic embedding
that seems useful
okay look
what i'm saying is
if we have tree layout
it's going to support some of the graph
layout options and not others
is that right or is that not right
i don't see why it couldn't support all
of them
and then maybe additional ones specific
to tree in the future
okay but you're saying the way it
specifies root nodes and things could be
different
yeah
so i i would can i take this tree and do
do can i run this can i what would i do
here would i say tree and then graph
layout blah blah blah no so
this is just in a branch right now okay
but if i said graph here and then say
graph layout does that work
i don't know of graph but maybe tree
graph
oh well that's going to be a problem
yeah because that tree has options
specified and that's going to be a
syntax error
for you
i see okay fine
um
should just regular graph applied to a
tree do the equivalent of tree graph
just as a courtesy
it could
uh there's the question of you know all
of the other graph functions that accept
uh
you know should you should you be able
to pass a tree in
to
graph functionality and have it
automatically convert to a graph
i don't know
we should inventory that
okay but so
what you're saying here
you know
we definitely want
okay do we want a separate tree
orientation
top bottom whatever because if you do
that and then you have a tree layout
and the tree layout is you know spring
electrical embedding it's like what the
heck does it mean to talk about tree
orientation
them you got what i'm saying
or hyperbolic or something
right
i i think the
main benefit of having tree orientation
is that you wouldn't have like if you
just want to change the orientation to
left well maybe what we should do is say
relay out layered embedding specific i
know i know i know it's just completely
wrong we shouldn't do that but we could
say something like tree layout our left
does that
right so tree layout
could support some of the graph ones
and it could support its own things
does that make sense
yep
let's try that let's see if that can
work
okay
let's talk about option globality
okay
by the way is there a highlight graph
can i use highlight graph to highlight a
tree
no
now so how would i highlight a piece of
a tree
presumably we would need a tree
highlight option
well okay but let me understand just
your option
your thing for options for trees here
so
what are you proposing here
so the main thing is the syntax for
specifying
positions so you can give a pattern that
matches against the positions
and then things matching that pattern
will use that style
that's the first thing
this is how dataset works too
okay
and then the second question is if you
don't specify it as you know a list of
rules like if you just say tree label
goes to red or tree color goes to red
um
does that mean just the specific subtree
is red or
all of them i understand i understand so
okay so hold on
first point is
you're saying so so in dataset
you're saying that background
is either red in which case just means
the background the whole data set is red
or
it's a list to position arrow red so to
speak
that specified what's that
yes exactly and and and you can have
patterns on the on the left hand side
right so that's a self-answering
question i mean because then
by analogy with that tree color arrow
red
should make the whole thing red
but the problem is
or at least the whole sub tree red
right
it wouldn't go up the tree everything
would be going down yeah right right but
i mean the question then is
is there a way of indicating
just this element
on here and i mean that would be
something you'd say empty list goes to
red there's an example of that uh
that's really obscure
that's really obscure
it's really obscure
it is obscure but it is consistent with
something for example extract
it extracts the whole object
i know but maybe there's a sugared
version of that that we could provide
um
all right what are we trying to do we're
trying to represent
by the way why does it have to have the
list around it here
probably for a single one it doesn't
have to
so then what we've what we've got then
is tree color arrow
i mean this is the form that we would
have
i don't even know how does that group is
that correctly grouped i don't know
um
actually
so so the fully general case would be a
list of rules so we could also say i
understand that's the single rule
by the way could you note down
that thing without the parens to put
that in the user assistance meeting to
discuss how we indicate what the
grouping is
um
okay i understand the fully general one
has
a thing that says okay so let's review
what what it is we're doing here okay
default case is
this whole subtree
okay
okay the other case is
i want to pick out some elements of that
subtree to
to
anoint so to speak to paint to whatever
else right so in other words i'm looking
ahead down the sub tree and i'm saying
pick this pick 3 2 pick 7 four
right right
and the other case of relevance is
i just want this
element here
so what's interesting about that is
if you look at the first two arguments
of tree
okay
one of those arguments is a subtree
designation and the other is a what
happens at this element
right
i don't understand that
okay so if you look at tree
yeah right
by the way i sure hope the tree plot
points to tree
okay
this
b here
is about this element itself
right whereas the second argument is
about the subtree
right
okay
what i'm wondering
you know for
uh grid we have the notion of item
that's a way of wrapping
options around a particular thing
you saw i'm saying yep
so what that would lead me to
is something where you could say tree
of item
a
you know
i don't know if this is a good idea
i'm not sure this is a good idea well
tree itself can have those options so i
don't think we need item here
no no i understand that but the whole
point is we're trying to deal with the
ambiguity okay so then there's a sub
tree here okay
so there's two cases
there's when
this represents
the whole tree the whole the
a and its subtree is red
whereas the first thing says a alone is
red
so i'm saying
yep
um
you've got
this alternative way of doing that
which is to say elements one two are red
three four are green
etc
okay
and you're degenerating that by saying
to get this element itself it's
that sub list
now obviously
i could as well say
in this case
you know would this work style a coma
red would that work
well so how do i change the size i think
i would i think that would work right
now and it would just make the a red
not the uh
vertex
does this work right now
no
well try it i don't think so
ah
okay we've had this issue
in
we have this issue in grid of whether it
expands to the whole grid element right
and we've got a solution there to that
okay so what is our solution there
right pick it up
okay
we don't have our grid experts here
item style
i think
i thought there was a way of oh yeah
here we here we go this is how it works
this is how it works
what i was saying there is right it's an
item
with background arrow red
you see what i'm saying
yep
as opposed to just the thing
so the correct version of this would be
i mean if that's in fact what we want to
do with this i'm not sure it is so what
other options do we have
do we have a size option what are the
what other local tree options do we have
here
we have colors just tree color tree
label and tree label style
what's a tree label
so by default the label is the data and
tree label lets you specify something
else to go inside
okay but that's utterly utterly uh
unbelievably flamingly obscure
if oh i see and the problem is what
happens if i said item there
unless we special case the item term
it's going to think that that tree
element
is
item blah blah blah
even though that's really just a
formatting thing
so tree label
is
the analogue of vertex label
which is even though the true name of
that element is blah
name it this instead
i see so the analog of vertex label
is wait a minute
i see is naming tree elements by their
part numbers
right
dessert i'm saying so so in vertex label
you can give
yeah so in vertex labels you give index
arrow label and here right you position
pattern arrow
value
right
can you give patterns for vertex label i
think you can actually i i should do
that i i don't tend to do that
do you think you can give patterns for
vertex label i bet you can
what's up i think so
okay
um
perhaps instead of item it should be
annotation
oh that's interesting
i mean we should be able to do
annotations on a tree presumably
right
um
okay so hold on a second hold on a
second
so the issue is does it affect just the
element or the subtree
okay how do we make it how do we
indicate that it's just this element and
then
i mean tree label
i mean clearly tree element color we
could have another option tree element
color
which would just refer to this one
i don't know what the heck tree label
that seems utterly obscure to me
i mean in other words that's
that's a spray labeling so to speak if
you understand what i'm saying
by spray labeling i mean you are at a
particular node in the tree and you
spray labels into subparts of sub trees
but we have two methods here you can
control everything from some root or
high graph node or you're going to
specify locally what you want in each
tree yes
and so our idea was that the deeper
object the deeper specification takes
precedence
sure
okay fine
but then so one solution would be a tree
element color
right i mean i'm not saying you can't
support
the um the null watchman trigger me yeah
but i think that's very obscure
well we could do the opposite we could
say three color red goes to
affects just this element and three
color blank goes to red or something
like that affects everything
further down which is
perhaps more readable
yes except the tree color would to me
not connote just that item
but that's an independent decision from
the rest of of the syntax
because the general syntax has two rules
three color rule pattern rule red
the three color red it's up to us what
to do with it
i know i know i know i know but i mean
i'm saying
so c3 label for example is going to
affect only this node so why not let's
say again what tree label
hello only affects this node
so we could say that three color red
only affects this node too
why is it called
tree label
see the problem is vertex label
i think it's confusing let me see tree
color right no i mean i mean it's like a
tree node label
are we calling them nodes
well that
that's why i didn't use the word node
because i'm trying not to never use the
word node
um
and the problem is tree element color
would be
well okay so one approach is tree color
as you're saying
defaults to the current node
right
i mean you know allowing the possibility
all arrow red as an alternative to blank
arrow red seems a perfectly nice piece
of syntax
the dataset also interprets all as blank
okay
well maybe this is right
to just have it be local to that node
i think that's less grotesque i think
it's more useful
so
we could
have all of these options consistently
do the same thing or have some of the
options
are inherited by default and some are no
don't don't don't don't have them all be
local okay which which ones might be um
well so for illustration purposes i had
tree labeled just being just this sub
tree and tree color and tree label style
being inherited
just so we uh
why do we need a tree level style
that changes the color of the label
well why can't you just do that by
putting a style wrap up for the label
i mean sure
i think that's what we pre-label style
is we don't have a label style yes we
don't have a vertex level style
really yes so tree color corresponds to
vertex style
tree label
wait wait wait wait wait why does tree
color
no we have a vertex color as well
i don't think so we have vertex colors
oh no we don't
oh yeah we have vertex style right
yeah
well maybe it should be called node
style
or just vertex style
could we reuse vertex style
why not 3 style
because
j style
because that strongly suggests it's the
sub tree if we said node style if we
really wanted to use
that then it would make it clear it's
that particular node
but tree style strongly suggests a sub
tree
but in a sense it can control the whole
tree it is that by default it just
affects
this string
this node
so
we have avoided the word node because
then it may
become confusing
yes
um
well look tree element style would be a
clear name
tree element label
these would i think be clear names
and
but but still they can have a list of
rules affecting the whole tree
absolutely
so if it is tree element style
and you say
all
arrow green
then that's fine it just says all of the
tree elements are green
right whereas if you taste tree element
style arrow green it means this
particular tree element is green
okay with this
tree element label
and you know in the weird case you could
say tree element label arrow all arrow
blah and tree element label style
i'd skip that one why do we need it
it's just a simple parody of the graph
right and other places like gridlines
and gridlines style
so there's a separate well i'm not sure
but but i mean
if we're going to do that i would have
thought a more useful thing to do
would be
let's see
you know
tree element label function
which
takes the
tree element payload
and derives the label from it
right that to me will be much more
useful and that's something i keep on
needing a graph
right in other words i have
some actual raw underlying names of
nodes in the graph
and i want to
you know process that
for the actual label
i think we should go with tree element
style
and tree element label
and wait on the
label style thing
and consider the possibility of tree
element label function
okay
okay
all right let's go on
so one question there is the defaults
for these things so
inherited versus automatic
we were thinking of considering them
equivalent
i don't agree i mean i think automatic
means the green thing
an inherited would mean from higher
higher in the tree
well in either case whether you use
inherited or automatic if there's
something higher in the tree you're
going to use that
if there's a spraying if it's an all
arrow whatever yeah if there is a rule
from higher up that applies there may
not be then you would use that
and then otherwise you would use some
default value
let's just go with automatic then
meaning that i mean inherited i don't
know what inherited means it could be
equivalent to automatic but i would just
leave it undefined okay
for now
i have a feeling that might be necessary
at some point what on earth is vertex
capacity i've never used vertex capacity
what is that
what is that
what on earth is that
is that for flow
you know this
somebody should clean this up and make
it clear what an earth this is
what is this
this is just crazy
okay
addison complained to the graf people
about this this is a this is a page that
explains nothing
i marked it down
i mean i can kind of guess what it does
but um
um
yeah okay all right i think we're done
with this
okay
excellent
i'm about to have another big
application for trees just to let you
know
great
um
okay all right great
let's go on to the next item
okay so here bill gosper has suggested
that we change
this case
in which we are always returning the
maximal length
so shift register sequence in this case
is always returning the maximum length
even if the cycle is shorter
i think he is correct oh yeah that's
crazy
okay wait a minute
just bonkers
okay so hold on let me just understand
uh background noise
background noise
that's me leaning back in my chair
waiting to hear how you explain the
defect in this function that you once
designed
[Laughter]
well you sound
a little bit jaded
no no i know i was complaining about
your audio quality not your comments wow
gives a maximal length sequence for a
size and linear feedback shift register
so
i think what is this the second
line with given taps
exactly it says it says gives the
complete sequence but
we don't say what complete means
exactly and it's completely bonkers by
by complete sequence what i thought i
meant when i designed that was the
sequence until it repeats
i see
not some puffed sequence so to speak
yeah this just seems completely wrong i
mean this is okay so hold on
so
it's easier to see the example in the
next section i think
so here we see
the cycle and what we return
compared
well it's just wrong we should just
return the cycle
right
okay
you know
that's you know
we're done this one yeah this one we
should just change it right
jose do you know i've had if we have a
bug report filed
it doesn't even say
i think we do
okay i don't it doesn't even commit
itself to what's going on so i just
think it's just a mistake and somebody
should tell gospel when we fixed it
okay okay
all right
wfr candidates just for a few minutes
well this is the meta conversation
which is how do we expedite this process
okay
um
a lot of the functions that we green
light really are specific to certain
groups
not all but many
and it might be more effective if we
went straight to those groups i think
you're right i think you're right i
think that this the stuff for this
meeting is
stuff that is in the ild wheelhouse
as
you know
that we could have invented specifically
here but it so happened to come through
the function repository yeah i think
that would be the
you know or or even we could we could
even take the spillover you know things
that
maybe we wouldn't have come up with here
but that don't seem to fit cleanly
elsewhere we can also consider
but um the
there's there's a an issue of follow-up
which is yes there is yes yes how do we
work on that
work through that see the problem is
what's happening is
okay there's ild
and there is a thing we've never built
which is essentially iad incremental
algorithm development
because what happens in the algorithm r
d operation mostly
is that it's working on big
sub systems right not oh let's add this
round like shift register sequence is an
example of an iad type thing that is
it doesn't really relate to much else
it's just a function we put in that's
useful am i making sense
i suppose it could be considered ild
it could be because it's just about
lists but i mean it's but my point is
think about something well let's see an
example of a of a thing that isn't an
ild thing that is a function repository
thing that seems like it has a you know
has a future
well uh i mean we can go right below
and uh yeah but most of these are not
most of these seem okay so ciphers for
example
okay i mean these things will be
connected into the cryptography
functions
yes now i mean my view of it is we if we
take them we should take them all have a
classical cipher and a classical d
cipher function and just have
you know a second argument saying which
cipher i don't understand why we're not
just making that part of encrypt why
isn't it the reason i think we shouldn't
is i think encrypt is a much more modern
type of functionality
and there's going to be many different
the differences in methods
um
under the hood are going to be
substantial
i don't i think this would just be
litter inside an encrypt function but
perfectly sensible in a classical cipher
function
just my view of it but but this is an
example of something that doesn't really
go to ild necessarily
it probably should go to a different
team
to consider among other things that that
kind of design issue
right well so there's a cryptography
group so it should go there
okay
so as long as it doesn't just get
rejected that's the problem well that's
where we come up with the issue of
follow-through
yeah
well i think we need to understand the
size of the problem because the things
you're showing here are mostly not
incremental algorithm development
right the things that i think about
other than development are you know look
the point is random functions in the
function repository that are useful
but
are not language type functions
yeah i i mean to give a quick estimate
i'd say maybe 30 of what we've green
light for further consideration
probably will end up with ild so 70
percent would not
give or take
okay magic square
we have already classified the
suggestions and we have already hundreds
so these are the language related so the
image processing etc
are separate well maybe we need a
separate meeting for those and then
let's see what happens for a couple of
those which groups are primarily
implicated
uh jose do you have that full list we've
got language we've got math we've got
image processing graphics and image i
think
we subdivided it
in in a way that was crude but basically
reflected the types of functions that
we're getting green lit for further
scrutiny
right i think we have like seven yes
that sounds right all right so we're
going to need some separateness for
those other groups like okay magic
square where does it go
not a crazy function for us to consider
having
this one we have in language
it's like ciphers and then suffolks
okay
okay
all right so you've you've identified
that as being
sufficiently non
algorithmic heavy lifting
right
yes we have clear statistics functions
and clear image processing functions
etc okay so asymptotes for example
of bezier interpolating control points
right so those are more in the math
category
right
oh we've got a lot of interesting stuff
here
are these the ones that are on our list
jose
no no no i've just i've just okay these
are just random yeah
okay
yeah a lot of interesting stuff
great
okay
the thing is some of that interesting
stuff
we decide in meetings should be looked
at for possible inclusion
in the language but then there's no
step forward from there we're trying to
funnel it through i know these meetings
and that's just not working
i think it's a question
okay i think we should do a sample of
maybe two other ones with other groups
and see what happens
okay and the conclusion may be
this is not part of our mainstream
development it's never going to happen
right okay
in which case we need to look at
you know some incremental algorithm
development effort
which i wouldn't mind seeing anyway it's
still going to be an issue because it
encroaches in other groups
well it depends on where that where the
resources for that group come from
right but if it's a new thing then it
isn't encroaching on anything no sure
but if 70
you know are are hitting um say
algorithms r d
uh or you know no i understand that i'm
saying if there is
a good reason
okay you know
if we want new people to work on iad
right
yeah that's a possibility i just want an
inventory is there a thing to do there
or are we going to say actually it isn't
you know we don't need that it's you
know these things are perfectly happy um
yeah
um
right i've got distracted because i've
got to go to another live stream and
i've got something i have to do right
before that
um
um
we could schedule a separate perhaps not
live streamed run-through meeting
i think
yeah i mean look what's gonna happen
here is
um
i mean this is gonna get more
procedural and management
related i suspect but
i think the first thing is inventory
does a group that is in a specific
development area think these functions
are worth having
okay
there's there's three possibilities they
don't think they're worth having they
say leave them in wfr
they say we'd love to have them we don't
have the the power peace people power to
do them but they fit into what where
what our plans are slot them in for two
years from now
or third case is
they're fine to have they're just
irrelevant to our mainstream development
there is no time schedule for them
there's a fourth case and it's the one
that i really worry about
and that is that we
funnel these to other groups and they
get
well but but then we need a definitive
thing if they say okay so here's the
question
and this relates also to project lists
and so on
if they say
this will fit into the thing that we are
planning for three years from now
then in many cases we'll say that's fine
they if they say this will never fit we
have nothing this is a proboscis
of you know of that is just hanging out
there somewhere and we're never going to
do it
that's a different case those are both
fine outcomes
well the outcome you're concerned about
is oh we'll we'll kind of get to it
someday i think the outcome the one i'm
concerned with is
is um
silence
oh yeah but but that that's why we're
going to have a meeting the meeting
won't contain silence
okay the meeting will come up with
something definitive and the answer will
be okay so here's what we were going to
insist on
either they think it should just stay in
wfr it doesn't need to get promoted
right
number two
they can identify what future project
that is in the project list
under
you know um on hold or green lighted or
whatever it is right
a future project that they can say this
goes into that future project
or three they say we'll never get to it
it's not in our plans
does that make sense
um
um yes okay let me um i need to run off
here and actually i'm doing another live
stream in just a couple minutes here
so
good
thanks guys i think that's a reasonable
plan let's let's implement it for a
couple of these topic areas should we
get a separate meeting scheduled yes
it's not an ild meeting it's a different
meeting it's a wfr promotion meeting
okay so i think jose and i should be
there
absolutely
yes i guess
okay thanks a lot guys right